louvroil 3600 habitants est une commune
de haute saône très mais très étendue
sur près de 5000 hectares avec une
multitude d'arbres continuons dans les
chiffres pour évoquer la fierté de
foudre hall ses cerisiers il y en a
plusieurs milliers avec lesquels sont
produits chaque année le fameux kirsch
de fougerolles allées tournant la
commune pour découvrir son histoire avec
l'église saint-etienne et son clocher
comtois du passé au présent continuons
vers le centre ville
et nous voici arrivés à la gare viotte
le seul cabaret de haute saône et les
caf ou drôles bonjour on tue la part je
vois bien que je vous fait rêver mais
vous êtes en avance le spectacle c'est
19h30 et 8 en attendant vous pouvez
aller visiter l'écomusée de fougerolles
vous allez vous régaler magicien à tout
à l'heure
thaler excusez moi car j'étais ici oui
c'est donc là bonjour la directrice de
l'écomusée ici après oui alors ça tombe
bien je suis en dessous tout savoir sur
le caire c'est une histoire formidable
oui l'histoire de fougerolles est très
liée à la crise et au kirsch on distille
dans secret des fermes depuis très
longtemps
au 19ème siècle cette activité s'est
industrialisée et en 1900 fougerolles
compte 40 distillerie industrie 40 d'ici
lundi
alors donc ça c'est le début c'est ce
qui a vu s dans les fermes
oui c'est assez l'alambic qu'on peut
trouver dans nos fermes pour distiller
d'accord et puis donc un côté y'a quoi
l'horloge alors ici vous pouvez voir des
alambics qui nous a dû tout début du 20e
siècle qui vient de la distillerie la
merci auprès du ru ouais mais qui
permettait de distiller de très grandes
quantités d'alcool pour la
commercialisation
donc là on vient plus dans un aspect au
commerce grosse quantité
ça sort des fermes oui il faut savoir
qu'en 1900 fusera les premiers pôles de
production d'alcool en france est encore
à l'heure actuelle nous sommes le
premier producteur en alcool de fruits
au monde on compte une visite
oui avec les
[Musique]
alors on continue cette visite dans tant
d'autres dans votre beau écomusée alors
ce qu'on voit c'est que à l'époque on
consommait beaucoup plus d'eau douce de
sa wii au 19e siècle les français
consommaient beaucoup plus d'alcool fort
qu'aujourd'hui tout au long du xixème
siècle la consommation d'alcool des
français va augmenter de façon
significative fin 19ème siècle en france
on consomme en moyenne 35 litres
d'eau-de-vie par habitant y compris
femmes et enfants mais ce n'est pas une
surprise puisque cette augmentation de
la consommation va de pair avec
l'explosion en france des cafés cabaret
troquet les autres bistrots sur le
territoire y joue le rôle du cul du cul
oui autres choses n'ont fait notamment
des très bonnes gâte pas très loin d'ici
ou juste la balle à faire un projet
[Musique]
patricia pascal c'est ça
bon alors ah bah oui je serai là ouais
et puis voilà c'est vrai qu'on est un
peu dans le on est un peu dans le dur
alors vous donc si j'ai bien compris
comme beaucoup vous produisez du kirsch
vous êtes vous êtes dans une
exploitation agricole et des bâches 40
points belliard et en 2009 vous avez
décidé de faire des glaces c'est ça
c'est cela même donc à l'installation de
notre fils pascal là on a voulu se
diversifier pour faire un revenu
supplémentaire
l'épaviste que par le kirsch ont pas
vivre que par là qu'ils rejouent par le
lait parce qu'on nous fait donc là nous
allons préparer une glace à sorbet à la
cerise donc ce qui est spécifique si
c'est que cette industrie zakir chat
des suisses de notre exploitation je
mets mon sucre l'eau voilà après il faut
mixer les fruits
essayez c'est terminé ça y est elle
terminée d'autant plus car vous me
l'avez tout à l'heure aux cerises elles
vont bientôt être bio c'est ça voilà
elles sont en cours d'agrément génial
alors voilà goûter cette glace n'a pas
volé plusieurs mais qu'est ce qu'on est
bien chaude voilà une offre latine là
elle est bien crémeuse aux excusez-moi
faut qu'on y aille à son terme vient
chez vous qu'on allait voir nos amis la
gare viotte voir s'ils sont prêts un
grand merci pour l'accueil
merci au recul on fait un plan complet
et on va jusqu ici
bonjour mesdames un jeu pas de si nous
voilà d'ailleurs à bienvenus nous y
sommes
alors dites moi c'est complètement
incroyable de voir un cabaret et drôles
incroyable une super expérience depuis
deux ans ici à la gamme viateur vous
avez un peu de ses grands spectacles
parisiens où les a amenés ici c'est ça
oui en province également on
le droit de se divertir avec un beau
spectacle alors autant plus qu à une
seule il ya combien de personnes 150
couverts et on vient de loin vous voir
huit de tout l'est de la france en bus
avec le seul cabaret de l'autre sont des
pratiquants de la franche comté le seul
merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]
et
m